Bonjour à tous ! Je suis très heureux de vous retrouver dans ce nouveau 3 théories
Comme vous le savez, nous sommes dans
l'attente du prochain film des Animaux Fantastiques
Puisque la saga comptera bien évidemment : 5 films
C'est un sujet que vous appréciez beaucoup sur la
chaîne et que j'adore énormément également, l'univers de Harry Potter
C'est pourquoi je vous propose de vous replonger avec moi dans cet univers pour parler de la saga
Et des potentielles théories quant au futur des films !
Ne tardons pas, je compte sur vous pour laisser votre meilleur pouce bleu !
Que les théories commencent !!
"C'est un pacte de sang... N'est-ce pas ?"
Dans le second opus des animaux
fantastiques, on nous présente la problématique du Pacte de sang
Dans l'histoire, il est dit qu'Albus Dumbledore et Grindelwald durant leur en jeunesse en aurait effectué un
Les empêchant maintenant de pouvoir s'affronter et de se blesser mutuellement
C'est pourquoi Grindelwald cherchera à recruter Croyance de son côté pour qu'il tue Dumbledore
Les deux sorciers étant chacun extrêmement puissant, personne n'arrive à leur cheville
Albus Dumbledore représente une énorme menace pour Grindelwald et inversement
L'un doit battre l'autre mais le pacte
les en empêche
Cependant, vous savez tous comme moi que dans l'histoire de Harry Potter il est dit qu'Albus et Grindelwald se sont battus en 1945
Ce combat se terminera sur une victoire de Dumbledore.
Mais est-ce que cela voudrait dire que le Pacte de sang est détruit ?
Un fait extrêmement intéressant avec Grindelwald est que scénaristiquement il est considéré comme le grand méchant de la saga des Animaux Fantastiques
Et comme un antagoniste du passé pour le monde moderne de Harry Potter.
Jusque-là tout est normal
Mais contrairement à Voldemort ou autres
antagonistes de la saga comme Bellatrix Lestrange
Et bien... Grindelwald ne meurt pas !
il est enfermé à vie dans sa propre prison à Nurmengard.
Vous ne trouvez pas ça étrange ?
Je sais que pour beaucoup le pacte de sang sera
détruit. C'est d'ailleurs la prochaine quête d'Albus à la fin des Animaux Fantastiques 2
Mais, si ce n'était pas le cas ?
Dans les faits, seul Albus Dumbledore peuvent vaincre Gellert Grindelwald et inversement
Les deux sorciers sont extrêmement puissants et seul l'un peut avoir le dessus sur l'autre
C'est pourquoi c'est à Albus de vaincre Grindelwald !
Et c'est ce qu'il se passera
Néanmoins le pacte de sang est là et il est impossible de savoir s'il peut être détruit
C'est pourquoi j'émet un doute puisque Grindelwald est encore en vie à la fin du combat
De plus, nous pouvons nous interroger quant à la baguette de Sureau dont Gellert en est le maître
Cependant, comme il nous l'a été démontré dans Harry Potter par le biais de Voldemort
Il ne suffit pas de tuer le propriétaire de la baguette pour en être le nouveau
détendeur
Le fait de désarmer la personne en face suffit simplement.
Albus étant le nouveau maître de la baguette de Sureau après son combat contre Gellert
Il est tout à fait possible que la fin
de la guerre soit le moment où Albus désarme Gellert sans le blesser mortellement ou physiquement
Ce qui justifierait le fait que grindelwald soit encore en vie, enfermé à vie dans sa propre prison et qu'Albus soit le nouveau propriétaire de la baguette de Sureau
D'ailleurs, dans l'histoire de Grindelwald, au moment où Voldemort vient lui rendre visite concernant ladite baguette
Ce dernier lui dit que jamais la baguette ne lui obéira et ne lui révélera pas comment l'obtenir et maîtriser tout son pouvoir
Une potentielle preuve d'affection, des années plus tard envers Albus. Son ami de
toujours
Celui qui a certainement épargné et refusé d'achever Grindelwald au moment de sa défaite
"Flamel vous pouvez le faire, nous croyons en vous"
Ce qui est pertinent et à la fois perturbant dans la saga des Animaux Fantastiques est que l'on connait déjà la fin de la série
La défaite de Grindelwald face à Albus. La survie de beaucoup de personnages dû à leurs actes futurs dans la saga Harry Potter etc...
La saga n'a donc pas réellement pour but d'instaurer une histoire phénoménale mais surtout d'enrichir l'univers
L'agrémenter de réponses manquantes par
rapport aux livres ou la saga des 8 films
Tout ce qui est montré dans les Animaux Fantastiques, chaque scènes et surtout celles avec les personnages que nous connaissons déjà ne sont pas là par hasard
Et c'est le cas ici avec Nicolas Flamel !
Je ne vous apprends rien. L'alchimiste est le créateur de la Pierre Philosophale
Un objet important du premier film Harry
Potter.
Et ce vieux personnage est rempli de mystères
Malgré le peu que nous savons de lui, Nicolas possède énormément d'artefacts et de savoirs dû à ses 600 ans d'âge
Dont notamment : ce bouquin avec un phénix dessus
La particularité de ce livre est qu'il permet de communiquer à distance avec certainement d'autres possesseurs d'un livre similaire
Flamel l'utilisera en urgence après avoir découvert les plans sombres de Grindelwald à Paris, pour contacter quelqu'un
Si je dis quelqu'un ce n'est pas par hasard mais parce que Nicolas tombera finalement sur Eulalie Hicks, la 1ère à répondre à son appel
Les autres photos sont vides signifiant
donc que personne d'autre n'a reçu son appel
Là où c'est captivant, c'est que Eulalie Hicks est une professeur de l'école de sorcellerie situé dans le nord de l'Amérique : Ilvermony
Et par rapport à la venue de Norbert dans la maison de Flamel sous les conseils de Dumbledore qui est lui aussi professeur mais à Poudlard...
Nous pouvons potentiellement en déduire quelque chose
Ce livre de contact que détient nicolas Flamel pourrait être relié à chaque école de sorcellerie du monde.
Il y en a 11
Par rapport à la détresse de Nicolas au moment de l'attaque de Grindelwald, Eulalie Hicks le pousse à aller combattre en lui signifiant que : "Nous croyons en vous"
Ce dialogue est lourd de sens quand on s'y penche un petit peu car Eulalie Hicks emploie le pluriel pour affirmer son soutien à Nicolas Flamel
Et également, elle le pousse à aller au combat contre le mal soit Gellert Grindelwald
Et si les personnages présents dans le
livre faisaient parti d'un groupe secret visant à veiller à ce que la paix règne
D'après les déclarations que nous avons eu sur la suite de la saga, il est apparemment dit qu'Eulalie Hicks aurait un rôle beaucoup plus important que dans le prochain film des Animaux Fantastiques
Mais aussi que les Animaux Fantastiques 3 pourrait se dérouler principalement à Poudlard ainsi qu'à Rio de Janeiro au Brésil
Dans ce pays existe également une école de magie
du nom de "Castelobruxo"
avec pour directrice : Benedita Dourado
Oh non je ne vous parle pas de la
moutarde
Si la théorie se veut exacte et que les
membres du livre forment une alliance contre le mal avec que des professeurs de chaque école...
Nous pourrions avoir la venue de ce personnage prochainement
Mais surtout, comme je vous le disais,
la saga des animaux fantastiques sert à
enrichir l'univers de Harry Potter
Nous avons connaissance que l'Ordre du
phénix a été fondée par Albus Dumbledore dans les années 1970
Le livre de Nicolas Flamel est orné d'un phénix qui permet d'ouvrir ce dernier
Le phénix étant le symbole de la famille Dumbledore... Et si Albus avait créé cette alliance pour contrer les actes de Grindelwald à travers le monde ?
Après tout, pensez-vous réellement que Albus ne fait rien depuis tout ce temps contre Grindelwald ?
Alors que ce dernier cherche à le nuire ?
"Je ne peux pas m'en prendre à Grindelwald...
Il faut que ce soit vous !"
Il y a quelque chose de particulier avec
Norbert Dragonneau
Il est le personnage principal de la saga des Animaux Fantastiques et pourtant c'est une saga qui traite avant tout de la montée en puissance de Grindelwald
Et de son futur combat contre Albus Dumbledore
Durant cette période de l'histoire, les personnages vraiment centraux sont
Albus Dumbledore, Gellert Grindelwald et Croyance Belleboss
Dû à sa condition d'Obscurial et donc son immense pouvoir
Mais alors c'est bizarre que le personnage principal que nous suivons soit Norbert Dragonneau.
Un Magizoologiste qui n'est pas spécialement un très grand sorcier
Peut-être l'avez-vous compris mais si Gellert Grindelwald s'est rapproché de Croyance Barebone, ce n'est pas par hasard
Gellert Grindelwald est une sorte de voyant et ce dernier a eu une vision concernant une force sombre, un Obscurial tuant la personne qu'il craint le plus au monde
Vous vous en doutez cela parle bien
évidemment de Croyance Barebone tuant Albus Dumbledore
Vous le savez aussi, le Pacte de sang
étant actif, Grindelwald et Dumbledore ne peuvent pas s'affronter
C'est pourquoi Gellert Grindelwald cherche à manipuler Croyance Bellebosse pour tuer son rival sans avoir à le faire lui-même
Mais vous le remarquez ici...
Où est Norbert Dragonneau dans tout ça ?
Pourquoi on le suit lui ? À quoi il sert ?
Et bien... C'est là que l'analyse peut être
intéressante
Norbert n'est pas un sorcier d'exception,
loin de là !
Il est quelqu'un de même très lambda
Cependant il est Magizoologiste
et c'est pour ça qu'il intéresse Albus Dumbledore
On ne va pas se le cacher, Albus Dumbledore est quelqu'un qui sait se servir des gens, surtout quand il a un objectif précis en tête
Je vous rappelle bien évidemment : Harry
Potter, l'Horcruxe caché de Voldemort dont seul Albus Dumbledore en avait la connaissance à la base
Et qui s'est donc servi de Harry Potter pour battre Lord Voldemort, même s'il tenait beaucoup à lui par la suite
Même Severus Rogue au moment de la découverte lui affirme que : "Vous l'avez élevé comme un porc destiné à l'abattoir"
De par sa condition de Magizoologiste Albus Dumbledore a fait appel à Norbert Dragonneau pour cette raison
Dans son passé Newt Scamander a déjà
réussi à contenir un Obscurus dans sa valise et à le retirer d'une jeune fille malheureusement décédée par ce dernier
Elle est là, l'utilité de Norbert Dragonneau !
Albus Dumbledore espère de lui pouvoir sauver Croyance Bellebosse et lui extraire l'Obscurus
Un sauvetage qui s'est malheureusement soldé de 2 échecs, étant donné qu'il n'a pas réussi à le sauver dans les 2 premiers films
Il est donc possible que toute l'intrigue de Norbert Dragonneau repose là-dessus
Scénaristiquement parlant, il est le "soldat" de Albus Dumbledore, tandis que Croyance Barebone est le "soldat" de Gellert Grindelwald, c'est comme un 2 VS 2
Plus on avance dans la série et plus il est possible que l'histoire se tournera vers Dumbledore VS Grindelwald
C'est cependant dommage que le rôle de Newt Scamander s'arrête juste à sauver Croyance Bellebosse
Mais qui sait ?
Il est possible que son rôle se développe encore plus
Mais à cause de sa condition d'Obscurial, il est fort à
parier que Croyance mourra dans les films à venir
Merci du fond du cœur d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
J'espère sincèrement qu'elle vous aura plu !
si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à laisser votre meilleur pouce bleu, un petit commentaire...
Et surtout à vous ABONNER pour toujours plus de Théories sur la popculture !
Vous pouvez également me suivre sur
Instagram : Argorok_Hugo et twitter : @ArgorokSkyward
Et/Ou me soutenir financièrement via Utip !
J'ai très hâte de reparler de Harry Potter & des Animaux Fantastiques avec vous !
Que le LionHeart soit avec vous bien évidemment,
c'était Argorok et Ciao tout le monde